listening to the body I think is  probably very underrated learning to  listen to your body and also having  patience knowing that okay if I rush it  today yes I have a competition coming up  in two weeks but if you rush it on a  hard session today that might actually  be more fatal yeah to to the end result  than actually just saying that okay  today I'm a little bit unsecure I go out  I go easy a little bit I feel how my  body responds if it's not there I'm just  gonna do a little bit go back and make  sure that I'm ready for the next session  again because one single session  will not make a big difference to the  increase in your performance but it can  be enough to basically tip the whole  result off in two weeks time if you  really if you start to rush it